so in Japan that was a little different
than Italy because we were filming a few
segments with you that we already
mentioned
um the kaiseki meal uh we went to the
Toto toilet showroom and then
um surprised some fans but you were not
in every segment so what were you doing
during your down time I felt uh
burdensome being on that trip yes I was
very self-conscious that because those
are you guys have small Crews and by
design that enables you to move around
if you were people to transport fewer
people to house and I felt because I was
only in a few of the segments and
arguably I didn't even need to be in all
of those segments I guess the kaiseki
one would be the critical one but you
know the segment with that married
couple would have happened whether I was
in it or not but did you come with us in
the other shoots I forgot I did yeah you
did I did uh I didn't go with you guys
when you flew to you flew up north oh
you missed out I didn't go to that one
but I went smart move I went to the one
in Tokyo and I felt uh like a burden but
no but you're also there I thought I
mean I think Conan likes you being
around we had fun times off camera you
could help find restaurants yeah
yeah there were a couple of dinners that
we had with Kona I was the sushi taster
yes right we went you guys were you with
you two were there yeah I was there we
went to a dinner at the Mandarin
Oriental school right which I had been
to previously and uh like to the
penthouse it was beautiful at the very
top of here's the thing about Conan he's
like uh he's portrayed as a sophisticate
okay he's like by who of a certain
stature he has an edge you know a formal
education he's got a reputation in the
comments we're getting a lot into his
Harvard Education I'm saying people
think people think he's you know a high
class I've gone and we've done Dartmouth
College we went to in November he's like
respected by academics yeah okay but
there's another side to him which
um I don't think people know about and
uh Conan uh is I'll just say selective
garbage Monsters uh sometimes and not
necessarily for health reasons you know
in the same way a child may not like uh
onions
he has some um preferences dietary
preferences so when we only eats Pizza
when we well he certainly loves uh Pizza
um but when we were yeah those are safe
foods for him but you know the thing is
when you go to a really nice Sushi
dinner in Japan it's almost always
Omakase where you don't choose what you
get the chef gives you uh course after
course and you would certainly not want
to insult the chef by not eating
something because as you may know Japan
values honor above potentially Above All
Else and uh the chef would put down a
piece of sushi in front of all of us and
I would he would the arrangement was I
was sitting next to Conan you guys would
just eat happily what was ever put in
front of you I would taste mine he would
look at me I would give him a thumbs up
or a thumbs down and I wasn't raiding
the quality of the food I was rating
whether he would like it and how do you
know if he would eat it I'll tell you
why
not I'll tell you why because he said
um we were talking about going to dinner
he said hey maybe we can go do a dinner
maybe some place that has like a salmon
sushi and I'm like that's like a sugar
fish or like I bet you this guy orders
from Sugarfish which was near his house
and he gets the salmon sushi and that's
like his safe thing that he likes the
fact that he deliberately said Sam and
Sushi tells me that he's very selective
about his Sushi and then I kind of guess
I had the conversation with him uh like
when eel would come I would uh give that
the thumbs down I loved the eel but I
knew that he wouldn't text her so then I
had to yeah that's the thing so I had to
eat whatever he rejected so the chef
would not be offended so and I know
makase dinners are ready quite filling I
don't eat so much I believe in small
portions spread out frequently
throughout the day I don't eat too much
anymore remember this meal not being
enough food wait so did you eat Conan so
I would eat the ones that he wouldn't
want so yeah so I ate I ate a lot
because so yeah he's was there a salmon
eventually was there eventually a salmon
I don't know that there was this maybe
because we have just ordered him like a
teriyaki bowl that no he would have
that's that's that that's against the
whole theory of an omanase dinner so yes
I see it different cytokonan but now
that's something you would do for a
child
yeah I'm not saying only for a child I
don't mean to offend a man that's not
even here but I'm saying let's be honest
if you had a child and you went to
omanakase dinner you you might taste it
and say you wouldn't like this one or
you know go ahead I wouldn't take a
child to an Omakase no have you done
that do you take your children to
omakasa I uh no I I uh I'm just using
that as a reference for his particular
brand of pickiness yes you know I I know
what he likes to eat and they're very
like they're typically very safe foods
bacon
potatoes like you know meat and potatoes
type
salmon wrapped in bacon you're like the
the King's food taster
I guess and they literally know his
palette and whether to give a thumbs up
or down I recommend it at one at a time
I don't know I don't remember the
chronology of that trip but somehow
Conan and I were on our own for lunch
just the two of us underneath our hotel
I think there was a concourse with yes
and I and and he said I need something
to eat I had just eaten I think I just
met up with him in the lobby uh
unexpectedly and he said I need
something to eat and I'm thinking like
what would he like in Japan and then I
came up with the perfect thing
absolutely perfect for him
fried pork and
um and we went there was one of the best
places was right in The Concourse and uh
he loved it oh good yeah and I I had to
eat again I had just eaten but I I guess
for whatever reason I felt obligated to
eat with him so that was another
situation but yeah fried pork is perfect
for him yes even even more so even more
so than salmon sushi yeah like I think
he's found his new go-to Japan
it's good that you shared your radio
time with Jason I was gonna say I'm glad
these beers are here because
[Applause]
answering the question no I
heard this book for two hours you guys
are talking about
my appointment calendar is two hours I
you could you're like we're wrapping up
already it's been like it's been like 23
minutes I I assume
ample time I couldn't believe we moved
on to Japan so cool
barely scratched the surface of Italy
Jason I have nothing else to ask that
was perfect we talked a little bit about
the Toto toilet showroom I uh this was
my first experience with Toto Toilets I
now have one at home
um do you do yeah I do do you have one
at home Jordan no I don't okay you know
the actual toilet or just like what's
the thing called tushy I have well it's
a Toto toilet with the
um with the bidet attachment yes bang
hot and cold or no no it's a more basis
yeah you're happy
they were impressive oh my god there was
one in our hotel
I mean it would open my friend you
walked in the door and it would open and
then it would single sing you a little
song oh it was the best and did it have
a face I might misremember it if I was
drinking like it was smiling at me
there was also a PR issue with them yes
um I remember at one point I was
instructed to sit on a toilet yes and
the the toilet was made to spray right I
was wearing pants oh right
um so my pants were soiled
they were wet no no yeah why would you
go there
I mean out of all the types
it doesn't mean anytime you hear soils
it's like I soiled my pants I said my
pants
I guess that might be a way it is I
guess that might be a way to say that
you soiled your pants it's kind of you
know you could have had potting soil on
your pants no this was this was water
and my pants were soiled with water okay
it was like a water stain my pants were
wet yes my fan my pants were wet so why
were they mad I forgot well the problem
is they are a dignified honorable
company right and they don't want to
show somebody toilets making fun of
their spray by sitting on a toilet with
pants on and having the spray they just
felt it was juvenile I don't disagree
and the point is my pants were soiled
with water
and uh and I was wearing those pants I
was wearing those pants for the
remainder of the shoot on the evening I
was sitting in the van with soil with
water pants
that was the last thing we did
nevertheless when you have wet pans in
that this is not my knees this is like
wet this is the entire buttocks and uh
probably
so that was an objection that they had
yes it got a little there was a little
tension I remember yeah there's a
translator going back and forth with him
about and then they kind of laid down we
had to quickly leave we we did Scuttle
out of there yeah yeah but in the end
like uh I don't think we portrayed them
in a negative light at all in fact it's
quite the opposite and we'll say flat
out they're like probably the best May
toilets my favorite year is recommend
those toilets and of course oh my God
they're Innovation the gold standard
yeah yeah we were the idiots we're
always the idiots yeah